we have three panels today first we
start with the communications workers
union and then we're going to be
listening to evidence from Royal Mail
and then from post office so good
morning to both of you Dave Ward who's
the general secretary of the CWU and
Andy furry who's the assistant Secretary
of the CW thank you for coming in uh
this morning uh Mr Ward just to start
could you give us an update on
um the current status of your
negotiations with Royal Mail please so
we've uh in a period of talks they're
meant to be intensive negotiations from
the 9th of January through to the 20th
of January
um we want to try and come out of that
with
there's a minimum a clear Way Forward
but hopefully to try and resolve the
dispute all of the issues that are
involved and I have to say that we're
we're still not confident that we're in
a place where we can reach that
agreement and so the union will be
rebaloting its members because we're at
a six-month stage coming up very soon
and we're confident our members will
continue to support us to try and get
the right agreement not just for our
members but also for the services we
provide and for customers businesses and
for the future of the company what we
want to do is align the interests of
workers customers and the company in an
agreement that that modernizes in the
right way I have to say very similar to
what we already had which was the
pathway to change agreement which the
company Renada
okay and Andy ferry from the post office
perspective
yes sir post office we are still in
dispute
um over pay freeze for uh 2020 stroke
twenty one and uh five percent offer has
been made for 21 uh 22.23 uh both of
those have been rejected by our
membership we have now conducted two
ballots for strike action
um and on both occasions they've been
over 90 yes folks currently got action
shorter strike action taking place and
unfortunately there's there's no there's
no talks planned I wrote to the chief
executive Nick Reed last week seeking a
meeting with him thus far he's uh
refused to to engage in negotiations
directly which is regrettable and we've
offered to call off the action uh should
that meeting get off the ground and
we're looking to to reach a settlement
for the last two years which are in
dispute and potentially this this coming
year so we're trying to look at all
different bases to try and find a way
through this but our members are
determined to find a resolution and are
willing to take further action and
unfortunately
um post office are not giving them the
due regard they as key workers that work
through the pandemic and clearly it's
not an issue of affordability
particularly as Nick Reed himself
doubled his his income and earnings last
year to 850 000 pounds from the previous
year so it's not an issue of
affordability here thank you very much
Ian Avery please thanks uh chair
uh Mr Ward morning
um the CWU have been in negotiations
discussions consultations whatever you
might call it with the Royal Mail for
months and months and months now with
regards to the current dispute can I
give the committee just a bit of a slave
of what's Happening here because people
are very much unaware of what is
happening behind the scenes what is it
going to take
what will it take to resolve this uh
this this industrial dispute I think
it's important that the committee uh
recognize that the Scout of what we say
is the most brutal attack on any group
of workers that the UK has seen for
decades that you recognize that it
really is a fight for the future of
every postal workers job for the future
their terms their conditions their pay
and for the future of the services that
Royal Mail provides to the public most
notably the universal service
where our concerns are is that the
company's whole strategy is not about in
our view modernizing it's a phrase
that's often used to put workers and
unions on the back foot as though we're
not up for change we had a change
agreement called the pathway to change
it would have brought in a 24 7 Network
we accepted that it would bring in
changes to try and capture parcel growth
going forward but crucially also so had
a strategy to try and minimize letter
decline because there was a recognition
then that despite the fact that letters
are declining there are so many
businesses and so many members of the
public that rely on those services and
also importantly it was an agreement
that we said that we would expand the
role of postal workers to bring in new
products new services that would
actually help grow businesses in the UK
would actually help grow the UK economy
more tailored services to local level
and postal workers were meant to be part
of that agreement what we've got now is
nothing more than an asset stripping
agenda it's the next stage of breaking
up the company
it's a leveling down agenda in
everything in the value of the jobs that
postal workers do
it's about replacing the existing
Workforce over time
with a new model which we've seen across
the UK which is based on self-employed
workers where they have to basically
take the burden of paying for their own
Vans they don't get holiday pay they
don't get sick pay they don't get
pensions it's all of that stuff that
we've seen in this country for too long
and it's about prioritizing the
shareholders in this debate over key
workers so during the pandemic our
members
um you know they were categorized as key
workers they kept the country connected
they kept Royal Mail going they got
Royal Mail to a position during that
period where they made 758 million pound
profits that was posted those profits in
May 2022 our concerns are that the
company have made two catastrophic
decisions
if they're going to say that they're now
fighting for survival financially which
we expect them to say today then they
need to face up to and be held to
account for the terrible decisions that
they've made under what we've called
gross mismanagement those two key
decisions that they made back in May was
one to give shareholders
567 million pounds of that profit
through shareholder dividends and
Buy-Back schemes and two to end the
cross subsidy of GLS now GLS is the
international company that Royal Mail
owns and if they're in that serious
trouble when they made those decisions
they knew there was a cost of living
crisis they knew there was a downturn
expected
across the UK economy but they still
chose to make those decisions which we
say amounts of gross mismanagement
what the workers are facing now compared
to the agreement that we had previously
is
um you know an attack on the number of
jobs the likes of which we've never seen
and you know the company has said to the
shareholders to the markets that there's
10 000 jobs we believe there are
thousands upon thousands more jobs at
riskier than the 10 000 that the company
are putting forward
um the company as I said want to replace
the existing Workforce
um they've they're Waging War on the
current Workforce the levels of
intimidation the levels of psychological
sort of bullying and to try and make the
job not worth them staying they want to
force people out of this business and to
replace them with a different Workforce
including agency workers and including
new entrants on 20 less overall paid
terms and conditions that's why we say
this is a leveling down agenda they want
to shrink the infrastructure so another
of our major concerns is that we believe
the company are deliberately running
down the universal service so they're
proposals that will affect effect postal
workers work life balance are to change
attendance patterns by up to three hours
in some of our big mouse centers they're
talking about early shifts that were
previously six o'clock in the morning
not starting until 11 o'clock in the
afternoon what we say is is that is a
fatal flaw in their strategy for growth
in the future that it will mean that
they're abandoning the am delivery
period and we expect the competitors to
move into that period once roll mail
move out of that period the strategy in
deliberately running down the Uso is
because they see it as a burden not as
an advantage and you know what we say is
any company that's in the logistics
sector the postal sector that's got a
reach of 32 million addresses every
single day of the week then if you can't
use that Competitive Edge then you
shouldn't be running a business like
Royal Mail and you know know our concern
here is this is the end if we don't
modify or significantly change the
planes that Royal Mail putting forward
then we believe this is the end of Royal
mouth as one of the iconic British UK
companies thank you I've got a quick
supplementary for Mark pausing Mr Ward
yeah I heard you just say that
um we're trying to get rid of the
workers
I mean we've taken evidence from
business after business which is sort of
people and we've heard evidence from
some public sector employees anhs
results where we're hearing that
employers are going to work for Amazon
and other such people because the wages
there are higher where if that that is
the company strategy where are they
going to find these workers that you
think are going to replace your members
well I think that's an excellent
question
um what is their strategy is in the
agreement that they're putting in front
of us which they call their best and
final offer although they've moved away
from that on a number of
significant errors in the last week or
two
um
what they want is unlimited numbers of
owner drivers self-employed workers to
come in they're not where they're going
to get them they don't exist they're not
in the work we know they won't that's
exactly the point that we're making it's
time to put they want to treat the
business essentially they want to shrink
the infrastructure of the business they
want to shrink the workforce and they're
saying that's because they're in
financial trouble and what we say is is
postal workers decent hard-working
postal workers across the UK who play a
pivotal role in the UK economy in their
relationship with communities Trust on
the doorstep which we own is being given
up because they've got a strategy and
you accept though that there aren't this
pool of workers available to replace
your members if they if they do what
you're suggesting which is try and get
rid of your members well I accept that
given the state of the UK economy at the
moment and what you've said I don't
believe the company except that
thanks chair uh Mr Ward you've talked a
lot about the pathway to change a
comprehensive uh National agreement and
you've attacked Royal Mail around gross
mismanagement and the attack on jobs do
you see this as an intentional
dislocation by management from the
pathway to change agreement and is that
in your view
deliberately so to Mark a breakup of the
organization a potential takeover what
what's behind this
well we really are struggling to
understand the rationale that the
company have put forward so we can only
conclude that after we reached an
agreement which was a another
groundbreaking agreement that would have
seen the interest of workers customers
and the company totally aligned in in a
real modernization agenda would have
meant a lot of change could have still
meant some people leaving the business
on decent voluntary redundancy terms the
company abandoned all of that process
that agreement they have renamed on all
aspects of that agreement they wrote to
the Union in September 2022 ripping up
pretty much every single agreement that
that the union has which protects our
members terms and job jobs and their
conditions that we fought for over many
many years
um what the strategy seems to be now is
purely to deal with the financial
problems that they've created a self-in
active wound and we're paying the price
for it is there sitting behind that a
potential takeover on Royal Mail in the
future we believe yes that is true
the government cleared the company Visa
private Equity Investment Group based in
Luxembourg to increase their
shareholding our understanding is is
that Visa continue to increase their
shareholding in recent weeks and we do
think that sitting behind all of this is
sort of bordering politics boardroom
power struggles about who owns the the
Royal Mail and you know our view is is
that the workers should have a greater
say in the company that they take great
pride in and have worked for for many
years so there are so many major
problems here that sit behind this
dispute and you know the frustration is
whenever you deal with this dispute all
people want to talk to you about is pay
now pay is hugely important for our men
members worst cost of living crisis in
living memory we want a deal on pay as
well of course we do but the changes
that Royal Mail proposing
um you know we are very clear will
shrink this company to a point where it
will not exist as the Royal Mail that we
know today and and with it is that
Universal service obligation then under
threat because we've we've heard the
attempts of the current owners of Royal
Mail to degrade that further and we've
assured by the Secretary of State that's
not going to happen but is that where
this is headed
it's definitely that the company do not
see the universal service
um delivering to 32 million addresses
every day they do not see that as an
advantage they see it as a financial
burden
and what we're saying is is that any
company in this sector
would give their right arm to be able to
have that infrastructure and we say it
is a fatal flaw in their plan to look to
end the Uso they've gone to the
government they went to the government
initially behind their backs months
before the official position there's
been a long-running Saga on this where
where previous CEOs as well try to go to
the government to reduce the levels of
service under the universal service
obligation look we we understand the
universal service can't be sustained
unless we innovate it unless we develop
new products new services and there is a
role there for ofcom as well and because
soft com at the moment we agree with the
employer on this point that ofcom are
creating the circumstances where the
universal service cannot continue
economically it's there for the future
if we see it as part of building growth
in the future future the Royal Mail
should be able to track their Parcels
through that currently of com are
denying them that opportunity so
definitely you know our view is is the
company are deliberately running down
the U.S so there are stories coming out
of every single delivery office in the
country that they prioritize Parcels
over letters they tell postal workers to
keep the letters in the frame they don't
give our members the overtime if there's
a problem with backlogs this is this is
what's been going on for months and
months they're quarter two results
performance wise I think it was last
year 2022 before the strikes had any
impact we're down to 80 percent delivery
of letters from 95 that is a deliberate
attempt to run down the universal
service to get the government to agree
to reduce service levels
thank you very much Ruth Edwards please
thank you chair
um this
you said that the Royal Mail was Waging
War
um its Workforce and that there was a
quite a lot of intimidation going on
towards postal workers that's a very
serious accusation can you give us the
committee a few examples of what you're
referring to yeah I mean we've had a
situation where people during the course
of this dispute in the lead up to this
dispute
are being bombarded with Communications
that are clearly aimed at demoralizing
the workforce there will be comments on
the CEO's own um you know workplace
social media platforms where you know
he'll say things that we say is gold in
the workforce things like well if you
don't like the change you know we'll go
and find another job
um there's a lack of Engagement going on
at local level there's imposition of
change on a daily basis our members you
know it's not just the days when we're
on strike that that our members are
under pressure because clearly you know
strikes are difficult in in the current
climate when they go back to work
they're denied levels normal levels of
overtime
um they're told
do this to do that you know they're
threatened if they don't complete the
work in the time that they're supposed
to finish the job by they're threatened
with delay in the mail many of them have
been suspended over 200 reps of the
union and members have been suspended in
our view many of those charges fitted up
to Target and intimidate people I think
it needs to be the postal workers
themselves we're just the voice of the
postal workers and we've never seen this
level of demoralization which we say is
deliberately being done to force a lot
of people out the job okay thank you and
just to clarify for my understanding you
seem to be saying that there was some
sort of unofficial repercussion
um for for workers as a result of
strikes is is that correct yeah it's
called the punishment Charter
um and it's always something that
they've been doing through this dispute
where when people come back to work
um you know they don't
um
they don't sort of allow them to carry
on working normally they allow they
force them into doing different things
they don't give them the earnings that
they used to get previously they've
attacked workers on sick pay
um where they start to
you know make out the the there's no
sick pay they don't believe if you put a
sick note in now uh the company
disregard that and automatically say
that you know you shouldn't get sick pay
until you can prove
um subsequently two weeks later so the
whole basis of how we work has been
ripped up by the company
thank you and you mentioned
uh workers uh postal workers being
punished for for delays I've heard
anecdotal evidence from postal workers
that the walk routes have been sort of
reorganized and that they aren't some of
them are now so large that it is just
impossible to deliver them within a
shift and as a result mail is going back
um to to the sourcing office is is that
your experience too that's exactly
what's happening what the company you're
doing at the moment is imposing change
by what we call managerial executive
action so with no input whatsoever from
Frontline postal workers they're
changing their routes they're adding on
to their existing routes and as we say
you know this is an attempt to do two
things one to get it in the minds of
postal workers that change is inevitable
so there's no point in fighting against
it if you like and two to demoralize
them so that they just accept the change
what we're saying here is we have never
seeing the situation where the entire
Workforce have lost confidence in the
leadership of the company we've had
disputes in the past but it's never been
as bitter as what this particular
dispute is thank you and Mr Fury at the
post office how are relations between
the post office and um postmasters
postmasters morale is an all-time low
unfortunately we believe that post
office is sleepwalking into potentially
massive thousands of closures
postmasters are really struggling to
make ends meet the reward that they get
for their Endeavors and labors is
poultry many of them are not even on the
the minimum hourly wage whilst they're
self-employed they're all really really
struggling and we're hearing ports every
single day where people are saying
they're just going to walk away from it
they can't make a living from providing
postal services so look the root of this
cause of all these problems is is
Horizon and that the inability of the
post is to deal with that and to and to
pay the compensation so it's going to
need a significant government
intervention to ensure that there is a
viable future for for the post office I
think we're at the Tipping Point where
if something is not done quickly then we
will see whole scale closures and the
postmasters lot is a very very difficult
one and I don't think the posters are
doing anywhere near as much as they
should be doing to protect and Safeguard
those hard-working postmasters who after
all
um you know are part of the
infrastructure of fabric of society
thank you very much thank you Alan Brown
please yes thank you
um just checking yourself I did it
turned to the The Horizon Scandal
um the criminal cases review
Commissioners noted they've contacted
326 individuals but they've only
received 39 responses in from the 39
only 22 former submasters have been back
in touch with them requests information
I hope they challenge their convictions
that that's almost seven percent these
potential wrong convictions looking at
going to the next stage at this moment
so we know someone the former post
office workers
Services
the review came and others traumatized
some are getting on in age obviously
from when the national s kind of
happened
what other obstacles other for former
workers and more importantly how can the
criminal review criminal cases review
Commission
reach more formal workers to get them to
Challenger convictions and is there also
is there too much pressure in
individuals to take this forward rather
than getting more assistance as it will
I think you accurately describe
um the the ongoing situation there many
of the postmasters that were victims
hundreds if not thousands of postmasters
some of them going back 20 odd years
um some of them may be too elderly now
to to pursue Justice on their behalfs
many of the postmasters are of of an
aging population
many of them won't have the the
financial legal support to be able to
pursue Justice through the CCRC
um and and I do believe that both the
post office and the government should be
doing more to bring to the the attention
of those victims that they have got the
ability to get redress and and get
exonerated and have their convictions
overturned
um I really do think much more should be
being done to financially support those
people but also to shine a light on the
on the the right to to submit those
claims to the CCRC in in in England and
Wales and all right and of course in
Scotland it was a separate organization
as well so
um I I think that that the post office I
understand they did write to everybody
who was convicted
um and say that there's now the ability
to to Lodge a claim but I think that
needs to be pursued with more Vigor and
more enthusiasm and I think more effort
should be made by the government and the
postwiz to do that it's ensured the
government post office should provide
financial and legal support to get this
moving forward okay thanks
um just moving on in terms of the
compensation schemes for the victims of
the rising scandal in short does it go
far enough what else again should the
postal office be doing is to help
postmasters
well I I ultimately I believe that the
many hundreds of victims and and it's
not just the ones that were prosecuted
and convicted it's also the people that
paid back the losses uh week in week out
from the glitches in the system I mean
this destroyed the livelihoods and the
well-being of thousands of people I
think the posters have got to go
significantly further here and and do
much better for those postmaster victims
after all it's the the actions of the
postmaster post office that have created
this situation uh and that it's not just
the prosecutions because many
postmasters were were frightened for
their livelihoods if they didn't put the
money into the deals week in week out to
make good then they were frightened they
would have lost their jobs they would
have been prosecuted so
um definitely much more should be done
but unfortunately and I'm sure Nick Reed
that the CEO will also confirm this
posters hasn't got the money to
compensate these people and therefore
the government is going to have to come
up with more money for this situation so
look I think the sir win Williams
inquiry is doing an excellent job to
shine a light on these problems but
ultimately the compensation that's being
offered is simply not good enough people
have had their lives destroyed they've
had they've lost their homes they've got
marital problems they've lost respect in
the community all of this situation how
do you put a price on on compensating
people for their lives being turned
upside down for so many years so I think
so much more should be being done by
both the posters and government But
ultimately the process needs more money
to be able to resolve this problem
and just one quick question on General
operation the post office so I
representative construction says got a
lot of rural Villages and I've noticed
that a lot of post office franchises are
effectively disappeared with a back door
so it should still be a post office
there but the post office say they can't
get into operate a franchise from a shop
quite often talk show up ones are
telling me there's not enough incentive
for them so there's a post office do
enough to maintain these Services rural
areas or is this another rationalization
in the stealth well this is why the
poster should have a real good core of
directly managed crown post offices
because by franchising them to separate
companies companies like RS McCool when
they decide to and when they decide to
walk away from them then and there's no
substitute replacement services then the
communities and the customers lose out I
do believe that we are really a Tipping
Point here where services in urban and
rural Rose can be be under a massive
threat where post Masters whether
they're franchises are part of a a
symbol group or whether they're
independently run I think the whole
process network is under immense
pressure and significantly more needs to
be done to put new new work there new
Revenue new income new transactions and
to diversify and become much better at
what they do you only got to look at the
models of Po how post offices are run
Elsewhere on the continent uh lapostin
in in in France the financial services
that La post does actually is is greater
income and revenue than the male side of
about the other thing here is that of
course there's been an artificial
separation with the umbilical cord cut
between Royal Mail and post office where
it was one entity it's the only country
in the world where the the males and
Parcels have been privatized and the
network the retail the post office has
remained in government owned and that's
not helpful for both organizations CW's
policies they should be brought back
together again
okay thank you we're already over time
but I've got two bids for
supplementaries if colleagues could keep
it to two three minutes each maximum
please otherwise I'll need to cut in so
I've got Mark pulls in and I've got you
in Labor I just want to go back to Mr
Ward if not maybe Mr Ward um uh the raw
male has got two bits of business it's
got letter businesses it's got Parcels
letters under massive pressure from
people sending stuff by email now so
Banks don't send out statements and
people weren't even sending Christmas
cards so that volumes have decreased
massively and on Parcels Royal Mail have
got some very agile competitors who are
very flexible and able to adapt to the
changes in the market given those
pressures on the business that's
available your members isn't it really
dangerous for you to be taking the
action you're taking at the moment
we we've not had any choice
um but to take the strike action because
we are fighting for the future of the
service
um in our members jobs are on the Fret
um that we're talking fast well let me
explain
um what we want is an agreement that is
about real modernization we had that
agreement previously so we would
recognize the points that you're making
but with the company at the moment
they're not interested in building a
proper growth strategy for the future we
will accept and move towards the the
position where the company can be agile
so a 24 7 network but there's a
fundamental disagreement we do not
believe the company should be abandoning
the am delivery period so the point I
think I would say to you is is that
what's crucial is that we have a
strategy that's actually going to
succeed in the future and not one that's
just going to be satisfied
shareholders in the short term do you
recognize the action you're taking is
encouraging the customers of Royal Mail
to seek alternative methods of getting
whatever it is they want delivered
well it's what I said earlier on that I
would say to customers of Royal Mail
that we're actually fighting for their
services for the future we're fighting
for them we've got plenty of
Alternatives well that may be the case
and they'll have to make that decision
well they're making a decision and it's
affecting from a trade Union perspective
from from a worker perspective from from
the workforce who actually do care about
the service we're entitled
um to put forward our ideas and our
other company can be successful in the
future and and therefore we've got to
continue to be able to do that now look
let's hope that negotiations can resolve
this dispute what that will take is the
company stop imposing executive action
and actually sit down with a union and
do a genuine agreement that is in the
interest of customers the future of the
company as well as the workers that's
what we want are you not worried about
the time you get there the business will
have shrunk so much that there will be
redundancies well of course we're
concerned about that situation
um but the blame for that lies with a
company if if they hadn't your members
will suffer now look if they hadn't
every night on the agreement our members
are suffering now under the plans that
Royal Mail putting forward believe me
thank you that was a good three minutes
Ian Avery three minutes I'm just just
very very briefly I think Mr Awards
answered the question I was going to ask
you know the there hasn't been a
resolution to this uh dispute uh what's
the barriers I think you have more or
less explained it just uh in the last
couple of minutes what's the barriers
and
what's going to take to resolve this
dispute
I think the barrier is uh number one uh
do the company actually want an
agreement or do they believe they can
achieve success by imposing change
without the support of the workforce we
believe that will be a catastrophic
error
and two that the strategy in a business
must look to expand the role of postal
workers you can't shrink
to Greatness in a business like Royal
Mail you've got to utilize the existing
infrastructure to build new products and
new services and we believe there are
lots of examples of where we could be
working with the company and using the
skill and the experience and the trust
that postal workers have on the doorstep
to do exactly that so the strategy is is
crucial going forward also on on jobs we
cannot support an alternative resourcing
model companies in the UK's biggest role
now this country can't carry on with
this type of leveling down approach
whenever there's a problem whenever
people start to say well how do you
solve this problem the answer is is will
you smash the business up and you just
look after you know break it up sell
bits of it off and bring in a new
Workforce on less terms and conditions
we're not going to accept that postal
workers phone owner Fortune at the
moment but they're decent hard-working
people and this can be a successful
business if we get a the right alignment
and if the company listens to the views
of the workforce and obviously what the
union are putting forward as part of a
deal for change
okay thank you very much that brings the
first panel to an end David Ward Andy
Fury thank you so much for your time
this morning we're grateful and we're
just going to swap over the seats
um and now white welcome Simon Thompson
who's the chief executive of Royal Mail
uh to the fronts
good morning
I'm sorry
I need to get some more stuff over here
again good morning good morning Mr
Thompson right we will get going
um Mr Thompson I understand from your
record you were appointed in 2021 is
that right yes
was this the first time you've been a
CEO of the business uh tis is a CEO but
I've had extensive experience around the
world in many different categories why
do you think your predecessor has
criticized you in public for not having
enough experience in mishandling the
situation
you know I really believe in Royal Mail
I believe in the brand I believe in the
opportunity to grow the business I think
we've got a absolutely wonderful
opportunity ahead of us I think when the
board made the appointment for me it was
around understanding the customer
understanding the digitization of the
business
and getting the changes that we need to
win
and I was listening to the debate just
before and I think it's important just
to hone in on the changes that we need
you know what I am doing and what the
team are doing around me is making sure
that we can compete in the parcels
Market I think that the reality that we
face is that letters were 20 billion
letters a year we did back in 2003 2004
they're now around about 8 billion so
our Core Business as we had before is we
used to deliver to you know two letters
per day per household we're now down to
around about one letter per day for
every other household that business has
really gone a massive Decline and during
that period of time as well the number
of houses that we've delivered to has
increased by around about 4 million from
around about 31 million to 4 million so
the reality is we are going to ten
percent more places and yet our business
is down 60 percent so what I'm focused
on and what the business is focused on
now is growing in that Parcels market
we've spent 900 million pounds investing
in to be able to compete in the parcels
Market you know we've got our great
super herbs we've increased our
automation we've made some great
progress but what we really need now is
the change in the working practices so
we can turn that investment into
competing in as has been said here at
the committee a hyper competitive market
thank you um you didn't answer my
question my question was why do you
think your predecessor criticized you in
public work for not having enough
experience and not handling this
situation well well I think during this
dispute there's an awful lot of things
have been said that have been very
personal I think that it's not necessary
I don't think it's nice and it doesn't
change the fact that what we need to do
is change the business and compete in
the parcels market and that's what
myself and my team are definitely
focused on just now you said to the
committee that you were appointed to CEO
because you understand your customers
and digital Solutions you didn't say
workers do you understand your workers
Mr Thompson absolutely and one of the
things that I've really dedicated my
time to is I've been the CEO has been
out and about actually with the
workforce
um you know I'm out and about on a
frequent basis generally absolutely
every week I also put in place workplace
as well which I know was referenced
earlier on we have around about 50 000
of our team on workplace and it's great
that they've now got a voice and what we
put on that platform is real key
information about the changes that we
need and it's always good to get their
reaction now of course I understand that
I will always explain the changes that
we need I understand that that is not
always welcome but I think it's really
important that we have an open dialogue
with the workforce
why were you given a bonus of 140 000
pounds last year
you know the bonus that was paid to me
last year
was based on the business performance
last year and based on the criterias
that was set by the remuneration
committee at that point in time
when I looked at the long-term
investment plan uh parameters for the
calculation of your bonus I'd noted that
the board had changed the way they
measure your performance so
traditionally it would be looking at
Revenue profit service level delivery I
understand it's been changed to just
shareholder value is that why you dished
out so many millions of pounds last year
instead of investing it into the
business because it creates the
opportunity for you to get a larger
bonus
no not at all In fairness my bonuses are
based on improving the business
Constitution changing the revenue
growing the profitability and also
improving in areas such as CO2 but you
know I'll come back to what I did I just
check because if I've misunderstood then
I'll I'll apologize but I'd read that
the 2022-23 the long-term investment
program for bonuses for you and your
colleagues on the board had been changed
because according to the organization it
couldn't accurately measure your
performance on revenue and profits
because of the states of Affairs at
Royal Mail and therefore it only looked
at shareholder value is that not right
oh my my incentives are based on making
sure that we deliver good quality to the
customer and also make sure that we grow
the business and so there wasn't that
change no there was that change and I
understand the point you're making but
in terms of what I focus on every day
when I'm focused on every day is making
sure that we can give the best
jobs in town and the long-term job
security for the team and we really do
need that change and and it's not change
that I'm doing for changes sake it's
change based on the changing needs of
the customers and the reality that's
around us the point I'm trying to get to
is that you are incentivized as the CEO
of Royal Mail
purely by delivering value for
shareholders it doesn't really decide
depend on how you get that I mean
ideally you would get shareholder value
because you run a profitable happy
successful business but actually if you
cut costs cut Investments cut the
workforce and still deliver a large
dividend you still do well out of that
don't you
now what I'm focused on as I said before
is changing the business so we can
compete in the parcels market and we've
invested that 900 million pounds I'm
pleased to say that you know our super
Hub in Warrington has come on stream and
that is working very well the other
Investments we're making in the Midlands
with the super Hub is also coming on
well we've grown our Parcels automation
from some 20 odd percent uh it's now up
to over 70 percent what we need is the
ways of working so that we can really
compete in the market and I'd also like
to add as well that during my time here
as CEO we've really led the initiative
around low CO2 for parcel the next
Battleground that is out there and I'm
it's great to to be able to report that
because of our feet on the street model
and our investor investment in electric
vehicles that we're really leading in
this initiative and that's something
that'll be good for the future of the
business as well as Society well I
congratulate you on that but if you
don't have any work as Mr Thompson I'm
not sure it's all going to go very well
um in terms of your transformation plan
which external advisors are advising you
on the transformation of Royal Mail
and we do have a number of advisors but
I when I came in from uh from a CEO's
perspective I've changed an awful lot of
the executive team internal advice is Mr
Thompson no I understand but one of the
three questions if you could answer it
please well we do have some external
advisors like all large organizations
resources
the point I would like to make is that
my question is which external advisors
I'm not asking you to make a different
point I'm asking you to answer my
question well we'd have an awful lot of
external advisors that do advise there's
a lot of those Agreements are actually a
confidential thing I think that if if
Rich advisors are advising you on the
transformation of Royal Mail if the
committee would like some more
information on that then that's why I'm
asking you the question what's the
answer please we'd certainly write you
and give you that why can't you tell me
now because some of those agreements
that we have with the external
organizations have an element of
confidentiality and I don't want to make
a mistake here and get that wrong but
we'll certainly write well I'd encourage
you you're covered by parliamentary
privilege Mr Thompson so no one can sue
you that's why you can give us honest
answers the reason I'm asking this
question is because if you look at the
wider industry a certain set of external
consultants and advisors are advising
all businesses to invest in technology
and automated devices in reducing
headcount for workers and using
self-employed drivers and cutting costs
and all of the things that we're seeing
at Royal Mail and you might see that in
Amazon or every or other types of
companies where this committee has heard
testimony of working conditions being
entirely unacceptable for those people
you're just following a similar track
aren't you because you're being advised
by probably those same Consultants no I
don't agree with that I don't think
that's the case at all here we're very
very proud that 97 of our team are
actually full-time employees we're very
proud of the fact that we give the best
terms and conditions in town and there
are things that we are determined to
maintain
what does PBA stand for Mr Thompson I I
don't know actually I apologize I don't
know what that stands for I was told by
one of your employees that I don't know
what PVA stands for but it sounds
similar to what Amazon uses and they
gave testimony to us about this a few
weeks ago apparently it's a bit of
technology that tracks how quickly uh
your staff are processing packages and
letters and getting them out the door
and that you're using technology to
decide on the length of roots the speed
at which they should go and I've been
told by some of your workers that
they're having to run from door to door
because the technology is telling them
they need to be quicker do you have that
technology in place Mr Thompson no I'm
not aware of technology that we have in
place that it tells people to work more
quickly I'm not aware of that at all
you've not used technology and
automation to decide the size of Route
no we do have a revisions exercise in
place where we have a look at the
volumes that are required in Roots and
this is this is normal standard business
practice and something that we've done
for absolutely many years to make sure
that the workload for each individual
route is actually equal between each of
the team and one thing that I see when I
go out and I get asked the question very
often is that why is it that some walks
might be two hours long and some walks
might also be four hours long and what
we do is a regular revision exercise to
make sure that those walks are equal
and so you're telling the committee that
your members of Staff don't carry bits
of Technology whatever that might be
that tracks how quickly they're doing
their job no they do they do have a PDA
and that PDA doesn't oh it was a PDA not
a PVA ah did I miss here on the phone
when someone called me so you do know
what a PDA is do you yes what is that
yeah a PDA is a device that our workers
will have which actually helps them in
terms of knowing where to go in their
route and also might be scanning items
at the doorstep you are doing exactly
the same as other employers such as
Amazon and using technology in this way
no well we do use Technologies which is
a normal course of our business that we
do but I I the the point that you're
making about you know does this device
tell people to go more quickly is not
something that we do but of course why
are you tracking the speed at which
employees are doing their work if you're
not using that for any purpose well what
we do is of course from a customer's
perspective what a customer wants is
something called an estimated delivery
window what we need to do with that
technology is sure which is based on the
needs of the customer that the customer
has an idea of the window when it is
that that product is actually going to
be arrived but we do not use that
technology in any form of way that when
anyone returns back to the office in
some form of penal way that is not what
we do
okay I mean Mr Thompson you're quite
good at evading my questions I mean the
points I wanted to make today was that
your bonus package had been changed in
order to just focus purely on
shareholder value that you're using
external Consultants to do what's
happening in the rest of the industry
and using technology in a way that adds
enormous amount of stress onto your
Workforce I think the answer to all of
those questions have in the long run
been yes and I would just politely
suggest you that when we've talked to
other businesses doing that it doesn't
really go in the interests of the
business their customers it's not the
best way to go and so I'll ask you one
more time for all the criticism that's
been levied at you for mishandling this
situation in the states of Affairs at
Royal Mail do not have any humility to
recognize that it's really not been
going very well since you were appointed
CEO I think that clearly there are some
things that have not gone as well as we
would want it I totally understand that
I think as a CEO of any business there
is no one there that we want it isn't it
your responsibility of course I am
accountable for the business I don't
think anyone would have wanted the
disruption that we've had for our
customers over the last uh nine months I
think that's absolutely clear
thank you Ruth Edwards please thank you
chair
um Mr Thompson can you explain the Cyber
incident that happened at Royal Mail on
the 11th of January which stopped
letters and Parcels being delivered
overseas
yes when I'd first like to say is an
apology to our customers that have been
disrupted by this particular incident
the second thing is I'd like just to
give a thank you to the national
security agencies that have been
supporting us in this particular
incident as well
the other thing is just to make it clear
for the committee is that I have been
told that to discuss any fine details or
any additional details on this
particular Topic at this point in time
would actually be detrimental
the situation that we have is that for
exports parcels and lessons through our
postal services that we are no longer
able to provide that service
but our domestic reality is that nothing
has changed all of those services are
working well and from an import
perspective as well that everything is
working exactly as it is that we need
so that is a situation we're at what we
said to our customers within you know
within a day of realizing what it is
that have gone on with the Cyber
incident because of course we have to
validate that it's not other things what
we've asked our customers to do is not
not to send us any letters and Parcels
at this point in time for postal export
in that situation and advice Remains the
Same today
thank you sir do I take it from your
comments that the incidents are still
ongoing then it hasn't been resolved no
the incident is still ongoing the
investigations are ongoing in terms of
but my sense is and the team have been
working on work around so that we can
get the service up and running again
that I think in the very near future
we'll have some more news to share
um um the very in the very near future I
mean it's already been down for for a
number of days now when do you think
you'll get it up and running again as I
said in the very very near future we
believe that we'll be able to give some
more information to the customers around
the workarounds that we've implemented
okay so you don't know
um and obviously if you're working with
the national security agencies I think
we can safely say then that you've
experienced a Cyber attack yes that's
right we've confirmed that we've had a
Cyber attack yes and has there been any
breach of personal customer data as a
result of this Cyber attack yeah based
on our investigations so far we believe
that there's been no uh compromising of
any form of customer personal
information there's a precaution we did
let the Ico know straight away if that
situation should change and of course we
let the customers and the authorities
know immediately thank you thank you in
Lavery please oh thanks thanks chair uh
I just want to say I think the uh Mr
Thompson has been absolutely
disingenuous when he mentions the
Italian because that's what it is
pursley's attired
if the or on the route and there's a bit
of a gap of delivery the whole into the
office and ask for explanations would
you deny that that's not my
understanding that's not something I'm
aware of no so you you see it's not
happening not to my awareness no no
that's astonishing coming from the chief
executive not understanding not that the
positive today are basically turned
during the the the time of their
employment from morning till the end of
their delivery no I don't think that's
the case we we have technology in Pace
in place to make sure that it assists
people in terms of the roots on where
they go it's actually very very helpful
for people that are new starters as well
and I'm not aware of any form of penal
system I think that you've described
that would say that at the end of a walk
that somebody would be I can't remember
the words you see it all into the office
hold into the office is not something
that is not something that is our
standard that's for sure
and I'll just referring to the financial
viability of Royal Mail uh and it's a
it's a massive concern uh particularly
under your watch Mr Thompson
um
up to March 22
the company made 758 million pounds
profit
567 million pounds was given to
shareholders
um immediately that was any
consideration whatsoever
and the Halcyon dealers of 758 million
pound to even think about rewarding the
people who provided the service and
provided that profit you're basically
immediately dueled it out to
shareholders and dividend who does I
mean that's extraordinary and then
within days the years might be an
exaggeration but certainly weeks
um the the Royal Mail the unannounced a
loss of one million pounds per day
that's absolutely incredible I've got to
see and at the same time under your
watch under the watch of Mr Thompson
chief executive of Royal Mail uh he
announced uh redundancies tens of
thousands of redundancies you won't
introduce agency workers on insecure
contracts every single performance
Target in the last two years was missed
by your company on their your
stewardship and for the last two years
and as already has been explained the
former Royal Mail chief executive
recently said that you were extremely
inexperienced and labeled the leadership
of Royal Mail as toxic and
confrontational do you really think that
you're a fitting proper person to run
this National infrastructure company
I think I want to roll back to some of
the information that you've mentioned
there I think if we go back to the point
of privatization Royal Mail uh between
our group of Royal Mail and GLS Royal
Mail in the UK made around about 83
percent
of the turnover represented 83 of the
turnover in the business for a
profitability perspective was around
about 73 percent
where we're actually at today is the
Royal Mail in the UK from a turnover
perspectives about 60 but from a
profitability perspective it is zero as
you've quite rightly identified we are
losing a million pounds a day
I think in terms of the dividends that
you've mentioned there was back in 2018
when we actually cut so I started to cut
the dividend payment based on how it was
that Royal Mail in the UK was actually
performing during covert there was no
dividend that was paid and the dividend
that was actually paid that you referred
to there was paid by GLS the
organization that is now you know very
very profitable and is GLS that paid all
of that dividend from an investment's
perspective since privatization we've
invested around about two billion pounds
and 700 million pounds in the last three
years and under my watch 441 million
pounds in our future including our
superherbs our electric vehicles and
also Automation and you know we've
really invested in the organization to
make sure we can grow
during the time of covert as well when
the shareholders did not get a dividend
we also paid 2.6 percent uh sorry 2.7 in
terms of a pay increase to our workers
as well
you accept that the former Chief
Executive said that your style of
leadership is
um toxic and confrontation no I don't
think we're toxic and confrontational at
all and what I would say is that what
we're really really focused on is making
sure that we can meet the needs of the
customer and we can grow this business
which we all want and I heard Dave talk
about it as well and I'm totally aligned
with that absolutely a lie that we want
to grow the business and give our team
the long-term job security they deserve
and we'll only do that through changing
and growing the business and also
maintaining the best conditions in town
and that's what we want to do
you understand why a lot of the posties
who have done a fantastic job are when
many you know in many ways are looking
to advance a company more than what the
management or themselves do you
understand their their anxieties that Mr
Thompson the chief Executives on 23
times their average earnings and as the
chair said
got a Bonus of a hundred and forty
thousand pounds at a time when the as
I've already said I'm not going back
over the world ground
um basically field as a company 750 odd
million pounds profit days after
um they're making a million pound loss
are you really worth that amount of
money Mr Thompson the 758 million pounds
you mentioned was made at a group level
um Royal Mail in the UK made 416 million
pounds over that 70 uh 758 million
pounds in terms of the pay ratio you
mentioned it's 23 to one is my pay
versus the postings pay our average
policies take home 25
000 700 pounds a year between eighteen
and forty percent more than the market
Norm I have to say from a personal
perspective and from a CEO perspective I
think it's very positive that these pay
ratios are have to be reported and I
know it's something that the
remuneration committee chair keeps a
very very close eye on
I mean it's very very good every kind
you see and it's good that it's reported
that that really wasn't a question I
said were you worth it
for the obvious failure Financial
failure of Royal Mail who you've already
see it as face and extreme difficulties
only your watch how do you get a bonus
for that well last year is different to
this year this year we are losing a
million pounds a day the situation is a
very serious situation which is why it
is that we're very focused on the change
that is that we need to meet the needs
of the customer and as I said before
we've done the investment in the
infrastructure that 900 million pounds
over the last three years and what we
now need is the ways of working change
to go with it from the team so that we
can turn that into a real growing
business and the only other thing to add
as well is a lot of the changes that we
are requesting from our delivery staff
are already well embedded in our
organization in processing processing
and other parts of the business as well
can ask another brief question it's
being suggested in the press that Royal
Mail Executives have been burstinged
about this war chest of
1.76 billion pounds it's been suggested
that perhaps this is a union busting
fund uh would you like the comment on
that
the 1.7 billion pounds it was referenced
so it's not a war chest what was
actually referenced was that it was
liquidity or access to money that the
organization could have but like any
access to money whether it be a loan or
a mortgage that you would have yourself
you have to pay it back so what we need
to do is turn around Royal Mail in the
UK get it back to a profitable
trajectory and then yes there is access
to money so that we can continue to
invest and grow the business
on the union busting side of things I
just want to make it really clear there
is more than one Union at Royal Mail we
also have unite a union that we partner
with what we did with unite this year is
have one of the largest organizational
changes that we've ever had in our
history in fact it's the first time that
we changed our management Frontline
management structure for 35 years some
of the agreements in there were over 40
years old and I'm pleased to say that
working alongside unite we delivered
that change very successfully that makes
us fit for the future and we also agreed
a pay deal with unite as well which was
aligned with what we've offered the CWU
and that was agreed within three weeks
so I think that we can absolutely work
with unions very well
and have shown that to be the case the
final final question on the universal
service publication we had the Secretary
of State
um here a couple of weeks ago and he was
asked if the company Royal Mail had
um written asking for the six day
delivery to be reduced to five years and
he said that there's nowhere that the
government were accepted and had said
that a Royal Mail win are you going to
stop pursuing
um they tried to get rid of the user
well the first thing to say is we're
very very proud to be the provider of
the Uso
um
I'm sorry I didn't miss it why are you
trying to dilute the U.S surf you're
very very proud of what it achieves
well what we want to make sure is two
things when the company was privatized
there were two conditions around that
from a Uso perspective the first one was
that the Uso would be viable
and the viability measure that was set
on The Uso was that the Royal Mail would
make between five and ten percent return
we've done that in two years since
privatization so there is a viability
question
the other side of things as well is what
is it that the customer wants and we've
talked about the changes in letter
volumes during this period of time as
well there was an off-com user needs
review that was done a few years ago and
what the ofcom user needs review said
was very very clear was that a five-day
service was something that would meet
the needs of 97 of people and again if
you looked across different locations in
the country and different demographics
the feedback was exactly the same and
what what we when we did our research
well the customer also said to us is
they want a seven-day Parcel Service
that goes everywhere for the same price
to and from their doorstep low CO2 with
deliveries by The Trusted poster that
everyone loves and Dave mentioned
trusted the doorstep earlier on I'm
totally aligned on that as well
so what we want is a viable Uso and a
one that also meets the needs of the
customers and everything that we've seen
is that means that five days would be
fine when I spend time out and about
with our posties as well I think they
also recognize that maybe five days
would also be fine
okay thanks thank you Andy McDonald
please uh thanks chair am I right
sometimes I think in in saying we've
declared that you you have a bonus of
140 000 pounds what's your salary again
what's your best salary uh 540 000
pounds
and then 140 000 pounds on top of that
thank you
um but despite the job losses that Royal
males uh announced it's introduced
on a drivers into the business they're
on approximately 20 percent less pay and
insecure contracts uh and you've
retained and recruited thousands of
agency staff
so postal workers are going to lose
their jobs while casualized workers
replace them
that's
fire and replace isn't it
no there is no fire and uh rehire I
think is the phrase oh I didn't say
final rehearsal finally those people are
gone out the door they're bulleted
you're getting people back on casualized
labor is that the way to run a cherished
uh National Assets such as well now I
apologize I'd misunderstood this I I
apologize no that's that's not what
we're doing at all as I said before
we've got 97 full-time employment which
is something that we want I think in
terms of the agency workers you know we
did have 18 days of industrial action
and we did have to make sure that we
kept our service running and that did
mean that we had to increase our level
of agency workers to make sure we could
keep the service running during
industrial action days as well now what
I'm pleased to report and it was
something that Dave and I discussed was
that we would reduce those agency
workers which we've rapidly done and you
know we're back in talks now and we're
very pleased that we're back in talks
now and it will be good to get an
agreement as soon as we can
as far as perhaps pleasing to hear that
you you you're talking you one of the
reasons that you cited was the operating
loss of between 350 and 450 million in
2022 half year results was a direct
result of the industrial action so
what's stopping you from reaching an
agreement with the CWU to to end the
dispute
well we would love to get an agreement
and I'm delighted that we are back in
talks and you know Dave Dave called me
just before new year we had a
conversation actually on New Year's Eve
and I'm delighted that that has led to
where we are I think in terms of where
we've got to we have now made 12
concessions
um including an increased payoffer and
also items such as voluntary working on
a Sunday and I don't want to Prejudice
where we are with those talks but you
know we've got some more days to go and
I think that we should you know keep our
efforts to try and get an agreement what
we really need here is everybody
pointing in the same direction so that
we can reinvent Royal Mail for the next
Generations which means we can compete
in that Parcels market and as I've said
before we've got the infrastructure in
place it's there ready it's coming on
stream we're making progress with it but
we must have the ways of working and
it's an urgent situation because I think
as everyone here on the committee will
understand a million pounds a lost day
is not something sustainable forever
okay so if that's you've got those
losses why did you distribute was it 506
760 million that was distributed to
shareholders in 2122 if the if oil mail
is financially unstable how on Earth is
that possible that was paid out of gls's
profits as I referenced earlier on so
you you carved the business up to
justify this because what about
um the uh the sick pay that you're going
to be giving because you you've
announced that you want to reduce sick
pay for personal workers don't you
acknowledge that by cutting sick pay you
endanger them and their family as well
as create an extra pressure on the NHS
it's the Royal Mail you've got duties
Beyond any other business you're not any
other business you're the Royal Mail how
can you take such a step against your
own workers my colleagues talked about
your 1.3 billion pound War chest
is this a really fit and proper way to
run about run as such an important
business as Royal Mail and we don't have
the war chest as I mentioned earlier on
that was access to liquidity I think in
terms of sickness well the telegraph
described it as a war chest and it was
the Royal Mail stating to its own
investors that it had that money are you
saying that the telegraph are lying are
are they've been misinformed a
correction was made on that particular
article and picking up your point around
sick pay you know our current sickness
levels that we have in the organization
is around about three times the norm if
you look at ons results
I think if we have a look at the vast
majority of our team and it is a
magnificent team they take around about
one and a half days worth of sick
absence per year our sickness policy is
significantly more than any of the
competition in fact in some of the
competition if you don't turn in when
you're sick you get no pay at all
what we have is we have over the first
six months you can get full pay for the
following six months you can get half
paid those things do not change
and for the first three days of absence
in any year you gain you would get full
pay but what we recognize is that a an
enormous amount of our sickness is
actually in a small proportion of the
team so what we are currently discussing
is a change in the sickness scheme to
encourage people to come back to work
and I think we should touch on it what
we talked about earlier on we need
everyone back to work as many people
back to work as long as they are fit and
healthy of course because that is how we
can make sure we can deliver a quality
of service
so you're not going to cut sick pay at
all you're not going to take any any
make any changes that would reduce
workers sick pay whilst they're absence
due to ill health not a penny our
overall sickness policy is much better
than competition we are I asked you the
question are you going to make any cuts
to sick pay it's either a yes or a no no
we are in discussions about how it is
that we can make some adjustments that
would only impact a small proportion of
the team to encourage them back to work
that sounds to me like a yes you are
going to cut the sick pay for those
workers we are discussing how it is that
our sick policies can encourage as many
people back to work as possible and also
it's worth understanding that we spend
around about 250 million pounds a year
on sickness and our sickness level is
three times the industry Norm just
finally do you not understand Mr
Thompson that by giving these sorts of
evasive and avoiding answers you you
played fast and loose with the chairs
questions about the technology about the
acronym that was used shouldn't you come
in and said no actually what we have is
X or pedia whatever it is if you're
forthright and candid with us are we are
we then going to be able to trust you at
the moment these sorts of responses
where you don't give straight answers to
very simple questions is really causing
us some considerable difficulty do you
not see that
I I can understand that the situation is
sense I would always like to answer as
best as I can I'm hoping that I'm
answering the questions in a way that's
acceptable to the committee not to me
isn't it thanks Jeff thank you and
forgive me just for asking maybe a
simple question but when was the
decision taken to separate the parcels
the international Parcels Business from
The Uso obligations
I'm not sure of the the question I'm
sorry from your evidence today as I
understand it you've got a profitable
kind of parcels business you call it GLS
right ah sorry um and then you've got
the the letters business the USA which
you've been trying to reduce your
obligations under with the government
when was the decision taken to separate
the two
well they've always been two separate
organizations uh been separate for some
time it's privatization
um yes they have always been run as
separate businesses the GLS business as
a chief executive and the Royal Mail has
a chief executive which is me so I think
what you've been saying is the GLS bit
is profitable and viable but I think you
said earlier they're a viability
concerns about the Royal Mail bits yes I
think that's right but what I would say
and we presented to the market back in
November time a turnaround plan for
Royal Mail in the UK it can be a a very
very profitable in business that
flourishes but we just need the changes
that are based on the customer's needs
to make it that way
okay it just reminds me a bit of the
buses Mr Thompson when buses were
privatized the bus company CEOs say oh
we've got a profitable route here that
we can't cross subsidize to the routes
over here that are not profitable and so
then you cut the roots that are not
profitable and then local communities
often low-income local communities have
no bus and then the CEOs come to
government and the taxpayer and say oh
we can't cross subsidize the profitable
routes we can't take the profits but we
can't cross subsidize can you give us
some taxpayers money to pay for the
buses for people over here that need it
it feels like a very similar
conversation I think you're going to
probably be wanting to ask the
government for more money or a reduction
in the USA or something to make the bit
that you've described as being
potentially unviable viable aren't you
no I don't think that's the case I've
been clear on our position on the Uso
from six days to highways on the basis
of viability and custom and Eve that is
something that we have absolutely asked
for
but but there is a great future for
Royal Mail the reason I took the job is
that I absolutely believe in the
business that it can compete and
flourish in the market you know we do
have some great advantages Dave
mentioned it earlier on that we go
everywhere I think that's a massive
advantage and we've got great
infrastructure as well we've also
innovated in some really great Services
you know we uh we're uniquely positioned
to implement parcel collect you know
Dave talked about the fact that we want
a bigger role for postal workers I agree
with them you know parcel collect being
able to pick something up at the
doorstep instead of someone having to
drive and park to hand over a parcel I
think it's a magical thing and something
that's uniquely ours we've also
appointed a managing director of Royal
Mail medical so we are looking to build
some new businesses as well on the basis
that we go everywhere and also the fact
that we have that trusted relationship
okay thank you uh Jane Thompson please
sorry not Jane Thompson Gene hunt I
don't know James thank you very much
thank you very much Mr Thompson I've got
a couple of questions if I may on
service performance and so first of all
all and the Q2 performance figures in
2022 were not great from what I can
gather and targets were missed
um however Mr Ward The General Secretary
of the CWU said in his
um submission earlier on
um that reform plans were torn up in
September and that there was a power
struggle talk me through that
um what's what's going on in Q2 and then
what is happening about this torn up
um plans and what's happening in terms
of a power struggle yes I think it's
true and we can see that if we have a
look at our our quality of service in
quarter one I think in terms of first
class it was 85 percent and in second
class it was 96 actually very very close
to the Target that we have set and I'd
also say to the committee and everyone
else as well as it's always a
disappointment to me and it's something
we're very committed to to achieving
those targets however stretching that
they they can be
what happened in Quarter Two is that our
performance was lower it was 71 for
first class and I think for a memory it
was around about 92 percent for second
class now that was disrupted by
industrial action at the end
um I think that's the case and I think
you know if we have a look particularly
in December as a for instance we had
seven days of industrial action out of
the 23 days up until Christmas you know
we during that period of time will
deliver around about 30 to 40 million
letters on a day so clearly any form of
disruption is going to have a major
issue
on the quality of service reality but I
am also pleased to say that during the
Industrial action phases we totally
change the way that we did our sortation
Automation in our machines to make sure
we prioritized NHS letters and the likes
and we delivered around about 34 and a
half million of those critical letters
during that industrial action period by
prioritizing them thank you and thank
you very much for doing that with the
NHS letters actually I was aware of that
and it made a huge difference I feel
sure so my second question follows on
quite well actually from from that I
didn't appreciate that you'd made a deal
with unite within three weeks and yet
CWU are yet to come to an agreement here
so what is the impact of the CWU strikes
on the future performance and
development of the business and indeed
the competitiveness of the whole company
I think it was referenced earlier on is
the thing that we we need to understand
and I spend an awful lot of time with
our retailer customers as well asking
them what it is that that they want and
what what they really really need is a
quality service and regularity and
confidence and things can be delivered
and it's absolutely true to say that
during industrial action a depressive a
button that they will make a decision to
protect their business and their
customers and that business has gone
elsewhere but the other thing that they
tell me and they tell me on a very
regular basis is that what we are
building in terms of our infrastructure
the ability to take an e-commerce order
at midnight deliver it the next day with
low CR2 and delivered by a postee that
they trust is a magical thing
so the realities from the retailers is
they are having to make choices that I
don't think they would like to make I
think the choice that they would prefer
to make is put their business with Royal
Mail because what we are building is
exactly what they want
thank you very much thank you uh Ruth
Edwards please thank you chair
um Mr Thompson you've focused a lot in
this session on parcels and the
profitability of parcels so would it be
fair to say then that reports in the
media and from constituents that postal
workers have been told to prioritize
Parcels over letters are are accurate is
that Now official Royal Mail policy no
that's absolutely not true we've been
very very clear that there is no
difference between the two we've written
to our teams on regular basis I actually
wrote a letter I remember when I first
came in my first year to every postal
worker reminding them that of the
importance of letters but we do have to
recognize one thing particularly after
days of industrial action for anyone
who's been to one of our delivery
offices you'll all remember the frames
within the frames we are 100 optimized
for letters there's somewhere to store
letters but we are not at all optimized
for Parcels so we do have occasions at a
local level where for health and safety
reasons reasons there might be a
situation where Parcels need to be
delivered so that the postal workers can
actually get to the frames but that's
not our policy at all our policy is very
very clear that letters and Parcels are
equal
it's interesting though because this
situation arose in in rushcliffe and I
commented in in the local media about it
and as a result I was contacted by
postal workers from across the country
actually who who said the opposite and
who said that they have been
specifically told to prioritize Parcels
why do you think it is that so many of
them have have been told something
different to what is official Royal Mail
policy I I don't know the answer to that
question all I will say is that our
policy is very very clear that parcels
and letters are are as important and as
I said earlier on we're very very proud
to deliver the US Soil Service and we do
understand the quality is important for
letters and also for parcels
citizens advice have submitted evidence
to the committee ahead of this session
and their data has found that customers
are far more likely to experience delays
to letters than they are to Parcels does
that bear out in your internal data and
no I don't believe it does but I think
if the committee would like any more
information on that topic we can
certainly write to you but I did see
that information from citizens advice as
well and it was actually thanks to the
citizens advice recommendation some year
ago that we actually changed our service
update page to make sure that there are
any issues in any delivery offices were
very proactive and we let people know
thank you I think the committee would
like to see that information actually in
terms of delays to letters as opposed to
parcels and I think we need to put this
you know this this issue to bed once and
for all in a way so what what will Royal
Mail to be doing given that there is
this confusion as to whether Parcels can
be prioritized over letters or not what
will they what will you be doing to set
the record straight and to make sure
that everybody knows that that isn't the
case well we've always been very clear
it's very clear in our policies how can
you be being very clear if so many
people have the wrong end of the stick
yes well it might be time to
recommunicate again but I mean we've
always been very very clear that that is
the situation and that is our policies
through our managers and also with our
people we've been very clear about that
can I take it from what you're saying
then that there will be a new
communication now from Royal Mail to
make it very clear that Parcels
shouldn't be being prioritized over
letters because obviously people missing
letters are missing incredibly important
information about NHS appointments
paying bills all sorts of things yes
we're very happy to recommunicate our
policy that we've recommunicated several
times I think that's perfectly fine
thank you Mr Thompson I'm a bit confused
because a whistleblower wrote to me only
last week once we'd advertised this
session was happening to tell me that
you do in fact prioritize Parcels over
letters and in fact he sent me a picture
of a poster that's on his Rack in one of
your offices and I'll just read you what
it what it says here this is from last
week
where it says the future is Parcels
unless your manager directs you
otherwise these are your priorities on
delivery each day Number One Premium
items and collections number two large
Parcels number three lapsing including
all parcels and number four at least
half of the delivery points on your
frame including letters so letters are
ranked number four in the priority list
and only half of them so you're
unilaterally only delivering on fifty
percent of your USA aren't you Mr
Thompson I'm actually aware of that
particular correspondence which was done
in one delivery office and it was dealt
with and it was a local action this
isn't true who wrote this post to Mr
Thompson that is absolutely not our
policy well it's it's on a Royal Mail
poster that your workers are being asked
to read when they go to work if that's
not Royal Mail policy how else do you
communicate Royal Mail policy that is
not a that is absolutely not our policy
I'd remind you Mr Thompson the
misleading Parliament is not something
that we appreciate here on the committee
and I think if this is not the case
you're going to need to write a
sufficient cells afterwards to prove
that that's changed and Mark palsy
please thank you chairman Mr Thompson
we've heard about the dynamic
Marketplace
um you're operating in
um and I'm just wondering whether
you know I mean you've got a Workforce
who's been with you for some time in
many cases I mean I I thought when I
visited my uh told me that I post these
stayed for either six months or you know
their entire working career and many of
them do choose to stay there for a long
time do you think that the workforce
understands the changes in the market
and the needs to put the customer first
well our average tenure of service is
around about 17 years which is something
we're really proud about and I think
that that helps us massively with the
trust of the doorstep and the
relationships as well so we're very
happy about that reality but we do also
need to recognize that if you've done a
job in a certain way for a period of
time the change can actually be quite
difficult
but what we've also done and we've
worked with the CW on this particular
topic if you take Sunday working as a
for instance we've made it voluntary so
we are making sure that any changes that
we are proposing is something that
people can work with and can adjust to
over time but you know the realities of
a parcel Market is very different to a
letters market and I'll give you a very
practical example you know the latest
posting time for a letter could be five
or six o'clock in the afternoon would be
our traditional reality the reality is
now in the parcels e-commerce Market
those deliveries are at midnight and of
course we have to get those items to
everybody the next day
so that's a six hour difference so what
we are discussing is how it is can we
get later start time sometimes up to an
hour maybe two hours maybe three hours
so that we can make sure that those
Parcels which is now sixty percent of
our Revenue can get to the customer in
the right way for the right day because
that's what they need my question is do
you think that the workforce and their
representatives recognize the nature of
that change is or is that part of the
obstacle to finding a way through the
present problems well I think it's an
obstacle and I think it's something
that's going to need more explanation
but what I would also say and when I'm
out and about in the operation the
policies will say it to me quite often
that when they are home in the afternoon
I think they recognize when they look
out of their windows that they can see
the competitors delivering and of course
those competitors that are delivering
business that we could be doing and we
want to do
thank you
thank you very much Mr Thompson if I
might politely say so I've not been very
pleased with your answers today I know
this is a difficult job for you but it's
really important that you answer
questions clearly and might I say
um uh as honestly as possible because
your performance gives us grave concern
really about the narrative that you
provided today on many of my questions
today including when there's clear
evidence to the contrary you've
suggested that what we've been told what
the evidence suggests isn't true
something has to be true and I'm not
sure what that is um so I I wish you the
best in resolving this dispute I hope
that you take our concerns and questions
seriously and if this dispute and these
issues are not resolved in a timely
fashion we may have to call you back to
also further questions and updates thank
you Mr Thompson we're now moving on to
panel three and we're welcome Nick Reed
who's the chief executive of post office
Limited
foreign
good morning
we'll just let everyone get settled
hopefully you've got a clean cut out
thank you water great and we're going to
start off today with Charlotte Nichols
please thank you chair good morning Mr
Reed according to systems advice
analysis one in three rural post offices
are now provided as part-time outreaches
and in the last 10 years the number of
permanent branches has reduced by more
than a thousand what impact do you
believe that this is having on the post
office's ability to serve people in
vulnerable circumstances and those who
rely most on the network and its role as
a social and economic hub
a question
um let me first by start by saying the
targets that were set by the government
which are access criteria so we should
have
um 99 of the population within three
miles of a post office and 90 of the
population within one mile of a post
office and there are a series of other
metrics that are specific to vulnerable
rural isolated and uh Urban degenerative
areas where we have post offices in
place and we've over the last three
years we've succeeded in delivering
against those targets so I I recognize
and acknowledge that the physical
infrastructure of a post office is not
always possible particularly in rural
areas and we do our best to provide an
Outreach service which is uh what we uh
what we use especially in that Rural and
extreme rural areas where we actually go
out and visit vulnerable isolated
communities or individuals indeed and we
establish post offices mobile post
offices or they can be post offices in
libraries or post offices in pubs or
community centers so it's a way of
ensuring that where it's not viable and
I use the word there isn't the customer
demand or there isn't the social demand
to have a physical infrastructure or a
post office within a convenience store
or another retail outlet we have the
opportunity obviously to produce
outreaches and have an Outreach service
and and you're right the Outreach
service has increased but but I I would
stress that the overall access criteria
and I know that last week when Minister
hollenrik was in the Westminster Hall
debate he made it very clear that the 11
500 was a target for post offices that
he wanted to ensure remained and we're
looking forward to working with him to
ensure that is the case we still as of
today have 11
671 post offices that are up and running
cute we have been made aware of a number
of instances where post office branches
have been temporarily closed but have
never reopened which has effectively
meant permanent closure of branches
without consultation with local
communities or indeed their Workforce is
that a deliberate policy and in what
circumstances would the post office
consider reopening branches which have
closed temporarily
I know that the Citizen's advice and
ourselves have had a number of
conversations around what exactly is a
temporary closure and I think it is a
little disingenuous as a term just to be
very just to be very clear on on this on
this topic we are not obliged or the
post office is not obliged to
automatically replace a like for like
post offices if it closes or indeed open
another post office in the immediate
area clearly we would want to that is
our objective our objective very much
and the the standards that are set for
us is that we have access criteria and
that we have 11 500 post offices the
situation that we have with temporary
closures is we invariably want to open a
post office in at the same location when
it closes it's not always possible
primarily because the majority of our
estate 99 of our state are run by
franchisees and sometimes they go bust
sometimes
postmasters retire sometimes they're
just simply not viable and we get little
know warning as to when they're going to
close and I think we had the example
earlier on of mccoll's where 55 of the
post offices have shut and clearly
that's something then we have to run
fast to try and address and try and
replace so we're speaking with citizens
advice about this term temporary I think
it is a little misleading and we want to
make sure that we're all agreed what
does temporary mean and when we replace
post offices but I would reiterate
this year we have had less turnover in
post offices than we have done for eight
years so the churn as we call it in
terms of post offices we've only had 168
this year that have uh that have churned
which we are very pleased about it's
obviously a reflection on the fact that
we are working hard to make sure we're
serving rural and urban communities as
best we can
thank you I'm interested particularly in
constituencies like mine which don't
have a single banking Branch within them
and so therefore there's much greater
Reliance on the post office for banking
facilities
that I'm
wanting to know what the post office is
going to do to provide these communities
and again we've referred to rural
communities already and you've referred
to the three mile radius of course for
certain rural communities despite uh
being fairly close in proximity to their
nearest town there isn't in fact public
transport available between that
community and the town meaning that they
might not be very far on a map but it's
very difficult for people to get between
them particularly people who are elderly
and disabled so what will the post
office do to provide these communities
with access to Postal Services
it's a very reasonable question and I'll
pick it up in in two parts we have a
um a banking framework with the 30
largest banks in the country where we
provide withdrawal facilities deposit
facilities uh obviously the ability to
cash checks and also do Bank balances
and that's something that we feel is
extremely important access to cash this
country is extremely important 8 million
people use it every single day and we
know that there are two million who are
on bank to who do use and need cash and
access to cash
um we know that a third of Bank branches
are placed since 2015 and we've made a
very strong play to the government and
indeed to the banks themselves and the
FCA particularly that there should be
legislation to ensure that when a bank
branch closes there is suitable and
appropriate
opportunities for customers particularly
vulnerable customers to have access to
cash and that's something that we want
to play that's a role we want to play
you'll be familiar with Bank banking
hubs uh that uh that we're starting to
open we've got some 25 in the pipeline
now clearly that doesn't reflect the
number of Bank branches that are closing
and we've got to close that Gap because
otherwise as you say there will be cash
deserts and that's something that we're
desperately Keen to avoid
um I mentioned that we obviously have
the mobile outreaches that's what we use
particularly in our rural locations to
get out to vulnerable cast as I
mentioned before we are meeting those
access criteria but but you're quite
right to be concerned Bank branches are
closing more quickly than banking hubs
or access to cash is opening and how are
you determining where these banking hubs
are being opened as I said in my
constituency we do not have a single
bank branch but we are also see
enclosures of post office facilities
which is creating exactly the kind of
cash deserts that you've referred to but
I'm not aware of any plans by the post
office to be opening up banking Hub
facilities or indeed more post office
facilities within the constituency so
how are you determining which
communities are getting these banking
hubs
um the banking hubs are run by UK
finance and they have their own
operating company so we provide the
operational service for them so it isn't
our decision I know that UK finance and
Link can determine from their sort of
geospatial measurement where it is
appropriate to put a banking Hub where a
banking Hub is needed but we don't have
influence over that what we have is a
contract to run and operate banking hubs
as they're established so we don't have
an enormous amount of influence over
where they go we've just said that we
are Keen to run them on behalf of UK
Finance so that's absolutely the case
and going back to your question about
um post offices we have a very very
clear set of criteria the access
criteria is extremely clear we know
where we have to provide postal services
and we know where we have to provide
access to cash and we as I say are
fulfilling uh the six core access
criteria that the government has set out
for us as well as the 11 500 which sits
over and on top and above of that metric
I'm sure you've referred to viability of
branch is when you're making decisions
about Branch closures do you not take
into account what bank branch facilities
are available in the local area and
prioritize those branches for being kept
open well clearly as I say we we have a
number of criteria that we use to ensure
that we're delivering the access our
access criteria and to ensure that we're
supporting customers and communities
it's imperative we have a unique role to
play because we are a commercial
organization as well as a social
organization we take that extremely
seriously our Public Service ethos but
we also have to be realistic about what
it is that is viable and whether or not
customer demand is there where customer
demand is uh is is
high and strong of course we will be
opening post offices and trying to
ensure that we can find a franchisee to
do so but to your point we don't own the
post offices we franchise the post
offices and we need to encourage and
motivate and motivate different people
to come forward to run them as I
mentioned before we've we are we on in
in the middle of a very difficult cost
of living crisis but we're finding that
the churn and the the turnover for
postmasters uh is surprisingly low which
is a good thing and uh we think that um
that will become more difficult as the
year progresses but at the moment uh it
is something that is in control thank
you and my final question before I go
back to the chair in terms of post
office plans to overcome the increasing
number of part-time outreaches and
decline in full-time permanent post
offices does the slim down drop and
collect model form part of your plans to
fill these gaps
the drop and collect model for those who
aren't familiar is the sort of First new
format that the post office has
introduced in in about 10 years and in
essence what it does is it provides a
service for prepaid parcels and prepaid
postal services so
um that that would include raw mail drop
and click that would include labels to
go that would include parcelforce
worldwide it's a collection service that
we have uh identified for our inner
urban areas where we are
underrepresented and where we want to
make sure that we capture the parcel
market so absolutely not a substitute
for Rural Services it as I say it only
provides postal services so it's part of
our strategy to make sure that where we
are underrepresentative in large and
inner urban areas we have the
opportunity uh to capture some of that
market and it's I suppose it's important
to put it into context it's probably a
tenth of the cost of establishing a
local post office it's easy to train
it's easy to use it's low cost and it's
efficient and our pacemasters those who
are operating we have some 140 of them
now
um really like what it does because it
provides the opportunity to capture some
of that prepaid parcel Market uh that's
out there so it isn't a replacement for
outreaches or a replacement for any of
our sort of flexible models that we use
in in rural areas
thank you and can I just uh check about
the temporary closures issues to
understand if there's something we might
be able to help with I'm grateful to the
member for Martha tidford who's in the
public Gallery today
um who wrote to us about the traharis
post office in his constituency as an
example where it seems to have been
temporarily closed now for more than two
years
um there are local people that would
like to become postmasters of the office
to have it reopened for their local
community but there's no way for them to
be able to engage with you to do that
apparently there's been no advertising
around it there's not been a
consultation on its permanent closure
how can post offices be closed
temporarily for more than two years it's
not temporary is this I I agree and I'm
surprised to hear the detail that there
hasn't been any consultation we are
obliged in the first three months if we
decide that a particular post office is
too reopen to have a consultation from
three months onward it's an engagement
with the community as it's as it's
called but as I say at the very start I
think this notion of temporary is
confusing and I don't think it's
particularly helpful for everybody we
obviously want to and we have a team of
some 50
colleagues who are out there
provisioning looking for franchisees to
take on and run post offices in those
areas where we may have been uh
literally given six weeks notice that a
particular site might be about to close
so it's not always possible of course to
uh to open in these particular areas but
we do advertise and we have a team uh
that uh that that supports the
advertising of where we want to open a
post office so I I'm surprised and I'll
look into them at the table and
obviously get back to you on why that is
the case that'd be great if you could
dispatch someone have a look that would
be um much appreciated Gene hunt please
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed Mr Reed for coming along today I
want to talk about uh the vision and the
net for the network short and long term
but also about markets so a couple of
questions first of all I have a a an
example
um in my constituency in Barrow ponsall
where unfortunately the post office
closed down again perhaps about a year
or so ago
um I have had significant help from the
post office in trying to reopen it and
indeed I've written to every every shop
in the village asking if they would take
on a post office but still we haven't
been able to find anywhere yet you have
a market there what else could we do to
to help get you a market in places like
Barrow upon saw where you do have the
ability to take on more if only somebody
would take on the business
it's a good question I think are we
doing a good enough job advertising what
it is that the post office does I
suspect we could do a better job I'm
very very clear from a sort of long-term
Vision perspective that uh the postal uh
that well the males and Parcels Market
has a huge huge opportunity for us as a
as an organization that the banking and
cash and banking Market does too we have
an amazing travel business we obviously
provide great build payment services so
we think we've got four very very core
parts of this organ of of this
commercial organization that is going to
develop and to grow so if I think
particularly about
um the parcels business you've obviously
heard from Mr Thompson today and from
others we are looking to expand and
become the first Mile and The Last Mile
for um for Parcels in particular we want
to be an aggregator where we go out and
use Amazon every DHL dpd as well as
Royal Mail group and make sure that we
maintain that role as a community Hub
and we think that's very viable I mean
that's a very very
realistic proposal and proposition for
us and with cash and banking it's
exactly the same we see ourselves as
providing the cash infrastructure for
the country and we want to play that
role as we as we will see an
acceleration in Bank branches are going
to close and we want to make sure that
we're there for the vulnerable for the
isolated and for those in the in the
cash only Society who still are very
very important particularly in more
rural communities which is something
that we have observed so we think from a
proposition perspective we've got a
great proposition now I'm not familiar
obviously with your particular uh with
your particular site and obviously we
will look at that and try and understand
how we can better sell what the post
office does and the role it plays and I
think this is the interesting part yes
we are a commercial Network yes we are a
commercial business but I think
certainly from a uh from a governmental
perspective it's recognizing the social
role that we play and particularly
that's the role that we played during
the pandemic and at the world we're
playing at the moment whether that's
with energy relief schemes whether
that's with council tax rebates whether
that's what we're doing in Northern
Ireland that started yesterday in terms
of making sure we get to the 75 percent
of of the nation in Northern Ireland to
actually prepay their energy bills
getting cash to them that's not
something any other infrastructure could
possibly provide and I think it's really
incumbent upon this committee and upon
and upon the government itself to
recognize that we have a really really
crucial social role to play as well as
making it commercially viable and I
think that's something that we will um
we will be striving to do indeed I
couldn't agree with you more about the
uh the social aspect of it
um and indeed the tricky bit is if you
don't have an outlet there there is a
market there but you can't get to it so
it's an interesting thing and whilst I
was the minister for small business I
visited belper and saw your Co-op site
um so you had a post office within a
co-op that then became a banking Hub and
I I think that could be a good way
forward you've referred to some other
services there what else is the post
office looking to do to create itself
into a universal hub if you like for all
sorts of services that could then create
a vision and a more developed Network
pert even more more than 11 671
Outlets across the country in the short
and the long term yeah I think I think
the short term we are focused um very
very extensively on our males and
Parcels business that that is
um just under 50 of our total revenue
and turnovers I'm 330 million somewhere
in that sort of rain and so it's so
important that
um we have a very very robust
relationship with uh with the Royal Mail
group but more importantly that we
explore opportunities to do more we have
a non-exclusive relationship with Royal
Mail now and as I say we've broken deals
with Amazon with every dpd DHL we will
sell we are selling uh in 50 post
offices every product for the first time
so we've actually selling for the first
time in our history non-rel mail and
Parcels product I think that the getting
that piece right the first Mile and The
Last Mile uh for for customers in the
parcels Market is hugely important but
let's be very clear the industrial
action uh that has is going on at the
moment is threatening that business and
we had a very uh a very difficult
Christmas and pacemasters had a very
difficult Christmas as a consequence of
the uh the strike action it reduced our
our trade by 26
um and that is something that
postmasters will be deeply concerned
about so we have a vested interest in
making sure that the Royal Mail and the
CWU settle their dispute and that we can
get on and build our business both with
the Royal Mail and with the other
carriers as we see our our role so I
think from a vision point of view that's
where we're spending our time from a
cash and banking Point of View
um as I say we want to offer those
banking services it's really important
that we do that we think it's a huge
role to play but we are also a what we
call a platform
um Market the postmasters themselves
have done an enormously good job
particularly through the pandemic and
Beyond of building a great brand and
that brand we can use online and we are
using it online so our financial
services Business Online has been hugely
successful this year and we see that as
the ability to sort of trade off a
diversified business so you have a
diversified business that is generating
profitability online and we have a
postmaster population that is struggling
as a consequence of the the of the
strike and the strike action and we're
obviously looking for ways to make sure
that we can use the brand that we built
physically with what we're gaining
online to make sure that we can measure
and balance for our pacemasters and
that's something we're trying to do at
the moment so that you know
profitability is more broadly shared
thank you thank you Mark Posey Please Mr
have you just said that you're a
commercial business but with a social
role and you've spent a working career
in the commercial sector and now find
yourself running an organization that's
accountable to the government and yes um
how does that differ
um it differs massively we have a public
sector ethos and we've talked a little
bit about what the infrastructure of
this uh this country is uh about and we
see the post office as a hugely
important brand and I think we are uh
underplaying our potential role
um everybody's seeing what's going on in
the High Street you're seeing
um shops and retailers closing and we
see ourselves as being a Corporal part
of communities up and down the country
and that's something that we know that
we want to reinforce and so we do need
to look at what is the new model for the
High Street we do we do need to look at
what role can the post office play as
part of a community Hub whether that's
part of um a cafe or a food store or a
convenience store a retail store how do
we make the post office more flexible to
do that and that's something that I'm
finding okay in terms of accountability
you're not accountable to shareholders
for example you're accountable to base
I'm accountable to my I have a single
shareholder which is the government yes
okay do they interfere do they let you
get on with doing whatever you you want
to do how does that relationship work
how does that relationship it works very
well we have a collaborative
relationship I've I've had a number of
uh postal ministers this year as you'll
probably be aware
um and it is Collegiate and it's
collaborative
um but like any shareholder um you know
obviously they Place their demands on us
as well what would happen if there was a
difference of you if you wanted to take
the organization in One Direction and
yeah you know the government perhaps got
a slightly different priority how how
would that work well clearly I would
obviously be speaking with the uh with
the postal Minister and indeed with the
secretary of state which I do do on uh
quite regularly about the direction of
travel and where we want to go are there
any disputes about the direction of
travel no disputes about the direction
of travel
um there are obviously disputes the tool
are there any disputes at all um
obviously there are funding issues that
we have with uh in any business and it's
important to to recognize these funding
issues there are a lot of pressures on
the post office at the moment as you as
you're fully aware we're in the middle
of a public inquiry we're obviously
trying to fix and right the wrongs of
the past we're trying to address
compensation and clearly we're battling
like all other retail businesses in a
very difficult market so of course there
are and I recognize within government
that there are funding pressures
um uh you know right the way across
government uh
features of your business that you want
government to support you financially on
or are you able to do what you want to
do largely through your own resources I
I think you know one of the challenges
that any government-owned organization
has it has a single source of funding
and that single source of funding is a
treasury and clearly from my perspective
I'm looking to identify different
sources of funding so that we can borrow
to do different things and that's a
conversation I am having as we speak
with uh with Bayes and and with my
colleagues in in the department to see
if there are ways that we can diversify
our funding so that we can capture
markets is that with the view to making
yourselves more self-sufficient yes and
that that's working you're heading in
the right direction we're having those
conversations it's fairly early doors um
at the moment in terms of what we're
doing but um you know clearly those
conversations are wrapped up in some of
the more challenging conversations that
we have around you know making sure that
we run
um a very very efficient Network and
also at the same time capturing those
commercial opportunities so that we can
continue to play a social role and does
the social obligation prevent you from
being as commercial as you might like to
be
no I don't think it does I think I think
it's very difficult to separate the
commercial and the social I think it is
part and parcel with a public sector
ethos of what the post office stands for
and what the post office is and I think
that's the strength of the brand I think
that's why we have such great trust and
I think it's why for instance that we
can be as successful online as we are at
the moment so in terms of the post
office Insurance in terms of our foreign
exchange business and in terms of how we
do business online that is built on the
fact that people know that we are
government-owned that we have a clear
mandate and that we have a very trusting
Network that helps build that brand I
think that's a very very important
characteristic that we lose at our Peril
thank you thank you just a quick
question on financial performance at the
post office I can see that you've had
trading profits now for a couple of
years which is a positive turn of events
compared to previous trillion years
um but still you have overall statutory
losses of 597 million in 2021 300
million in 2020. a huge percentage of
that is obviously compensation for the
Horizon Scandal but if you take out the
Horizon Scandal costs I think the post
office overall is still still loss
making is that right it is but we are
it's important I think to separate out
where is the subsidy that the government
gives us uh which is to to run obviously
the uncommercial elements of the network
um and again clearly that is part of it
but from a trading level uh yes you're
right we made 86 million I think it is
in 2018-19 uh then clearly and went in
the in the years of the pandemic we
dropped down to 35 and 35 we will
perform better this year as we emerge
from the pandemic and as I mentioned
before it's the ability to uh different
parts of the business can respond to the
market in different ways it will be less
successful
unquestionably uh in terms of physical
infrastructure of post office as in our
bricks and mortar business will be less
successful than our online business but
to my point before we will make a
trading profit bigger than we made in
the previous two years and obviously
we're looking at ways to make sure that
we can use that profit efficiently and
effectively to uh to to support our
pacemasters um out in the on the
physical High Street we heard earlier
today
um I think it was suggested that your
salary has doubled recently is that true
my salary hasn't doubled no
um yes I got a Bonus this year but my
salary itself I haven't actually had a
pay increase for three and a half years
so that's not strictly true and your
bonus I mean it's just a bit of a theme
of questions something I'm interested to
hear how Executives get bonuses when
companies are loss making
um how has your bonus performance
assessed my business performance success
on on sort of Three core criteria on uh
first and foremost fixing the past and
making sure that actually we make the
necessary changes to the organization
such that nothing like this can possibly
happen again in terms of the inquiry uh
clearly there's an element of making
sure that we fulfill our social
obligations in terms of delivering the
access criteria making sure 11 500
branches are on the High Street
um certainly amount is due to
profitability but I've made it very
clear that putting postmaster trust at
the at the heart of of of my business
and that's something again that I am
measured on as well in terms of how
postmasters feel the organization is
being run and that's the basis of their
remuneration on top of that this year
clearly we are trying to migrate off the
Horizon system as you'll be fully aware
it's a 20 plus year old system and I
think it's very important on a number of
levels one so that we can be
commercially more efficient and two I
think it's appropriate given the nature
of uh of what has happened in the past
that we make a clean break from that
system and clearly making sure we
execute against that is part of it as
well we also heard earlier that there
are sub-postmasters that are paying
themselves below the equivalent of the
national minimum wage and struggling to
make ends meet do you recognize that and
if so what can you do about it we're
very concerned um and as I mentioned
before we're very concerned as uh when I
look at the state of the estate when I
look at potentially 50 of the post
office estate is earning and generating
less than five thousand pounds of profit
energy alone we know that from speaking
to our postmasters they are likely to
see an increase of between six and eight
thousand pounds this year which is why
we lobbied very very hard for the
government that they should if they want
if they believe they are key workers
then they should be ring fenced
accordingly and I would emphasize again
I think that's extremely important so we
were disappointed uh when we weren't
given that key worker status last week
when the energy bills support scheme was
reduced to 400 pounds that is a
challenge for us and that is something
that obviously I will be taking up with
government because clearly that's
something that we need to ensure that
postmaster results
yes and we just also heard just to
finish off my questions here that um it
was suggested that you have refused to
enter into direct negotiations with the
Trade union I find that a bit curious um
Mr Fury rate to me on Friday uh inviting
me to uh to attend I've never refused to
meet the CWU and of course we have been
in negotiation with the CW uh fairly
regularly it was unfortunate that the
meeting at acas was postponed last
Wednesday but we are able to talk of
course we are okay so you will talk with
him thank you okay
um Ian Lavery please I think
Mr read what you said you hadn't had a
few increase for three years
sorry my salary is 415 000 year
and what was the bonuses you you've had
in the last three years
um I had a four hundred thousand pound
bonus last year I didn't take a bonus
the year before and I took a 50
voluntary reduction in my business deal
before that did you see a four hundred
thousand pounds that's correct bonus
correct
I took it
um in 20
20 2021 uh the post office made a profit
I think of 35 million pounds 20 21 22 39
million pounds and it was bonuses to
management tool and somewhere in the
region with two million pounds you've
all had a fantastic Workforce who
provide a fantastic service
um two percent they're three percent
then five percent and it still hasn't
been
um concluded will I be an improvement in
that offer to this fantastic Workforce
as I said before we're very keen to talk
to the CWU we want to make sure that we
get ourselves in a position where we can
obviously settle that would be
imperative I've I've made a very clear
offer that we will pay
um or back day to pay to the first of
April at five percent plus a 500 pound
sort of supplement for energy we want to
make those payments I'm happy to make
those payments now and not jeopardize in
any way people's ability to strike if
that's what they want to do and I'm Keen
to make sure we bring a resolution to
this
thank you Andy McDonald please uh thanks
chair reference The Horizon Scandal
history 95 of applicants to the
historical shortfalls game have now
received a conversation can you tell us
what the status is of the remaining uh
new claims and how the post office
ensure is ensuring offers are made as
quickly as possible I I can yes you'll
be aware that 2 374 people came forward
to it within the um the HSS scheme as
you identified this time last year when
I was here I said that we would Endeavor
to get to a situation where 95 percent
had had offers made to them by the end
of the Canada year which we managed to
fulfill and I think there is to the tune
of 74 million pounds officers were made
88 of those individuals have accepted
the uh their offers we've paid out to
the tune of 47 and a half million pounds
so far and obviously will make up the
difference so there are some there are
some well as say the last five percent
will be more complicated there's no
doubt about that though some of those
are later applicants some of those are
insolvences some of those are
bankruptcies and they will take a little
bit more time but I I'm very hopeful and
um we have set ourselves a Target to try
and complete these by the end of March
and uh we are on with doing just that so
my hope is that we will have completed
uh the entire historic shortfall scheme
by the end of March just just on that
just stepping back looking at
compensation more broadly yeah
um some of these postmasters have have
lost everything some have gone to jail
who've lost their Liberty their lives
have been completely ruined
um when we when somebody sustains such a
trauma
they usually recover their their losses
both past and future their pension
losses and they are compensated for that
grave insult to them in terms of their
loss of Liberty and the psychological
damage
whatever schemes are produced here it's
going to be a massive shortfall opposite
the true extent of the losses that these
individuals have sustained and if you
arrive in that position I think we would
want full compensation we talk about
full and fair it should be for
everything that they've lost don't you
think is that what that's where we
should be improperly compensating these
postmasters who suffered so the gravest
of insults in their lives totally ruined
I couldn't agree with you more and I
have been consistent in the three years
since I've joined the post office to
address these issues I mean the first
task I had was to settle a Glo it was
the first thing that I did when I joined
three years ago I'm absolutely clear
that we want to make sure that it's fast
and Speedy Justice that is delivered for
our pacemasters no question about that
at all you'll be very familiar there are
three schemes there's the historic
shortfall scheme which we've just talked
about and we are on with uh delivering
literally 100 of that by the end of
March
the overturned convictions are a
different scheme obviously but by
definition people will be familiar that
the post office between 1999 and 2014
prosecuted 706 individuals and clearly
it is our job to make sure we get out to
those individuals and encourage them to
come forward to have their cases and
their their convictions overturned if
they are and have been Horizon based and
what we've done to date is that we have
disclosed information to 153 only 153
and I recognize that that is something
that is of frustration to the committee
as it is to ourselves we want people to
come forward we believe now that we have
contacted all but 20 of those 706
individuals and we've used the CCRC to
help us from an independent perspective
encourage people to come forward and and
have their their cases reviewed by the
CCRC or indeed their appeals overturned
and clearly that is something that is of
great concern to me that only 153 have
to date done so and we need support and
we need help to do that I can completely
understand that will be many postmasters
out there who simply want to put this to
the back of their mind it's the last
thing they want to do is to come forward
and revisit what clearly was an
appalling time for them
um and yet at the same time to your
point we want to make sure that we
deliver Justice and we deliver it fairly
and that's absolutely my objective to
make sure we do that so we're working
hard to think through with the CCRC how
do we continue to trace how we continue
to encourage how we provide the
environment where people don't feel
threatened but that they can come
forward and as I say to date 83 have had
their convictions overturned and we've
paid some 15 million pounds out so far
to individuals both pecuniary and
non-pecuniary in terms of the claims
much more to do it is hard work
everybody is individual every case is
individual but we think we are making
good progress and it's very difficult to
assess you know how good is good
progress we all want it to be quicker
but be assured I absolutely want it to
be quicker and it's very difficult to
get a benchmark on how quickly you can
deliver justice of this sort of nature
now clearly I spend my time looking at
what other inquiries have done and how
other inquiries have uh have gone about
it whether it's gruntful or infected
blood or others but you know we want to
make sure that we can deliver it as
quickly as possible and we have as I say
a large team disclosing information
making things available so that uh so
that this uh this horrible and sorry
State can be brought to the conclusion
thank you it speeds good but full is
also important absolutely thanks Joe
thank you just for anybody watching
proceedings today just to reassure them
the committee continues to engage with
ministers as well as the post office and
the CCRC to make sure that everything is
being done for victims so that they can
come forward and be compensated and I
would Echo the comments of Andy McDonald
about that being full as well as their
compensation paid by the treasury okay
Mark fawzi please thank you chair I was
on the committee that looked into this
issue and we heard some absolutely
harrowing accounts of people running
small businesses who were accused of
stealing from the organization and it
was uh horrible to hear their accounts
and I welcome what you've said in the
work you've done to compensate people
and to uh to to try and set the record
straight I just want to ask you
specifically about the suspension pay
compensation scheme which relates to
people who weren't remunerated before
the contracts were suspended in March
2019 correct and the minister wrote To
Us in November saying that the post
office will write to all of those people
involved providing compensation on their
remuneration that they were not paid and
also in respect of consequential losses
has that has that been fulfilled the
process has started um we have the first
letters have gone out we've had the
first responses back so we think there
are some 3 000 individuals who thousand
three thousand who have had who receive
no pay during a suspension period and
clearly we're contacting all of them and
we're going to write to all of them and
as I say that process has begun and
we've already started receiving
responses to it and we have as I say
secured the funding to make sure that we
can make the appropriate have you got an
estimate the budget that will be
required for this compensation package
we don't know yet what that's going to
look like as I said in the region of
um many millions yes
all right okay thank you chef and the
treasury is presumably committed to
giving you the money right okay and that
brings the session to an end so Nick we
thank you for your contributions today
um I'll bring the session formally to an
end order order